on passe au débat de ce club et on va
évidemment parler du projet de loi
immigration qui est examiné en ce moment
même au Sénat et hier soir c'était le
point de tension qui était en débat en
séance l'article 3 qui a finalement été
supprimé on voit ça avec audre vetaz
c'était le point d'achopement de la
majorité sénatoriale depuis des mois
l'article 3 sur la régularisation de
plein droit dans les métiers en tension
les LR de Bruno rotaillot n'en voulait
pas les centristes d'Hervé Marseille
demandaient à conserver cette mesure le
Sénat l'a finalement fait tomber hier
soir pour
191 contre 138 le Sénat a adopté
l'amendement de suppression de l'article
3 une suppression possible grâce à un
accord politique entre les deux forces
l'article 3 disparaît mais en échange on
conserve un volet régularisation dans la
loi au cas par cas à la discrétion des
préfets et de façon exceptionnelle c'est
l'article 4 bis un accord félicité par
le ministre de l'intérieur avant d'être
recadré par leslr l'important comme je
me suis déjà exprimé c'est l'esprit de
compromis que veut le gouvernement pour
avoir l'essentiel de ce qu'il demande
une mesure de régularisation de
personnes qui travaillent dans pays
depuis très longtemps et dont les
patrons ne veulent pas les régulariser
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas signerf pour
pas qu'on découvre le poteose on va
sortir de
l'hypocrisie il y a une différence entre
l'article 3 du gouvernement au début du
texte et a une très grande différence
avec l'amendement à l'article 4 que nous
avons déposé on demande simplement par
principe que ce soit du cas par cas
c'est quand même une distinction
fondamentale avec learticle d'origine
donc que les choses soient claires que
la vérité soit dite que le débat a lieu
c'est très bien mais sur la base de la
vérité après ce compromis droite centre
et gouvernement tent de sortir par le
haut ce que n'a pas manqué de souligner
la sénatrice socialiste Marie-Pierre de
la Gonterie avec une légère ironie vous
avez un problème de communication entre
entre vous puisque chacun dit que il a
gagné le gouvernement aussi ce qui est
absolument rigoureusement impossible
donc on verra qui sortira gagnant à
l'extérieur monsieur retaillot a dégainé
le premier monsieur Marseille s'est dit
quand même non non non et puis monsieur
Darmanin bah c'est pas mal bon et oui
madame de La gonri c'est un accord
politique et un accord politique c'est
pas un gros mot vous allez tout de même
pas nous donner des leçons en matière
d'accord politique parce que quand on a
signé l'accordti
permettez-moi il y a plus de grand écart
qu' en a parmi nous désolé de vous dire
ça une bataille politique qui devrait se
poursuivre à l'Assemblée puisque
sachaoulier le président de la
commission des lois a déjà prévenu qu'il
réintroduirait l'article
3 AR qui a gagné la bataille politique
sur cet article
3 disons que dans l'immédiat
manifestement quand même votre invité
précédent monsieur peut être finalement
assez content du résultat du vote du
Sénat hier soir après c'est très
difficile de le dire ce qui il y a quand
même une très grande confusion et et la
trajectoire de ce texte est loin d'être
aujourd'hui assurée parce que on va voir
ce qui va se passer à l'Assemblée
nationale et on a le sentiment quand
même lorsque l'on regarde ça de manière
un peu granulaire et précise que Ben
monsieur Darmanin joue quand même au
sein du gouvernement une particion un
peu personnelle déjà de son côté et que
au sein même finalement de la majorité
ce qui va être voté ou ce qui est déjà
voté au Sénat n'est pas sans poser
problème lorsque le texte va arriver à
l'Assemblée nationale puisque déjà
monsieur Sacha Houlier le président de
la commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale vient de déclarer que le
l'article serait réétabli dans son
intégralité donc qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ensuite à l'Assemblée nationale
ou quand même c'est là que se joue pour
une grande partie le sort de ce texte la
question reste ouverte en tout cas pour
répondre à votre question très
rapidement dans l'immédiat en effet les
LR peuvent se sentir satisfaits en tout
cas au Sénat de la façon dont l'article
a été voté
benjaminr je suis assez d'accord avec
Arnaud c'est-à-dire que objectivement ce
texte il est orienté beaucoup plus à
droite que quand il est entré quand il
était déposé sur le bureau de cette
chambre évidemment il y a la question et
bien de ce fameux article 3 suppression
alors on maintient une disposition de
régularisation sans l'aval des chefs
d'entreprise donc ce qui permet en effet
de donner un satisfait kit à la gauche
parce qu'il pouvait y avoir un effet qui
était un effet de contrôle mais de
l'autre côté ça reste une régularisation
au cas par cas donc on n'est pas dans la
mouture dans la moulure de l'article 3
avec l'idée que la la régularisation
pourrait être un droit il y a pas que ça
il y a évidemment la me et cetera donc
on a un texte qui s'oriente beaucoup
plus à droite ce qui évidemment a permis
à la droite de faire deux choses d'abord
de maintenir la majorité sénatoriale
c'était pas gagné au départ et s'il y
avait eu vraiment des tensions au sein
de la majorité sénatoriale qui avait
fait que Union centriste tr c'était
déchiré Infiné au moment du vote ça
aurait été beaucoup plus compliqué pour
l'près et de l'autre côté le texte qui
sort c'est un texte qui est quand même
marque aujourd'hui à la marque de LR et
en effet le premier le ministre
d'armanin sort d'ici avec un texte mais
ce texte là il va avoir toutes les
peines du monde à le faire avaler à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'il est
est-ce qu'il est pas trop à droit du
coup et trop durci pour permettre le
compr le problème oui clairement enfin
clairement aujourd'hui quand on voit
encore une fois les réactions d'un
certain nombre de membres de la majorité
présidentielle à l'Assemblée nationale
si je pu m'exprimer ainsi pas seulement
les plus à gauche également au sein du
MoDem une grande partie du MoDem
aujourd'hui était plutôt favorable à
l'article 3 tel qu'il avait été rédigé
dans le le projet de loi donc ça va
inévitablement poser des problèmes au
sein de la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et toute la difficulté pour
Monsieur daranin ça va être de pouvoir à
la fois ben maintenir le texte tel qu'il
a été voté au Sénat mais de disposer
d'une majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
pour faire adopter ce texte donc moi je
le dit depuis le début je ne vois pas
comment l'exécutif aujourd'hui peut
faire l'économie du 493 pour faire
adopter ce texte quand bien même ce qui
s'est passé au Sénat d'une certaine
manière permet de reraccord ne rés rien
pour vous l'accord en tout
cas en réalité le gouvernement est un
peu prè à son propre piège quel était
l'objectif du Gouvernement sur ce texte
comme sur d'autres c'est de dire la
majorité LR de droite à au Sénat va
pouvoir engager le groupe LR à
l'Assemblée ça marche pas toujours mais
en fait ça marche relativement souvent
quand on regarde bien sur le textes or
là que va faire Olivier marlex que va
faire rxioti il va dire regardez le
texte il est bien je veux le même je
veux conserver le texte pas acceptable
par le modemme pas acceptable par Sacha
ouillet donc il y a deux scénarios
possibles soit ils arrivent à trouver un
compromis à l'Assemblée nationale sur ce
sur ce texte entre Sacha ouet et Eric
cioti sur un tel sujet très peu probable
soit en effet ils utilisent le 49 aline
à 3 mais s'il l'utilise il l'utilise
soit contre LR soit contre leur propre
majorité et là évidemment vous créez des
tensions profondes c'est le scénario
Macron à le comerie sous François
Hollande utiliser le 49 àine à 3 contre
une partie de votre majorité avec une
majorité relative explosé c'est très
très dangereux soit dernier scénario qui
serait peut-être même pire pour eux le
texte passe aux conditions de LR mais
avec les votes du RN et Auel cas c'est
ce que j'allais vous demander est-ce que
on va revenir sur le le 493 contre la
majorité mais là on parle de Sacha alier
qui représente la gauche de la majorité
qui est le président de la commission
des lois mais est-ce qu'il a un poids
plus important que s'il y a une alliance
entre l'autre parti de la majorité les
LR et le RN qui a dit qu' votre restex
il y a pas l'article 3 bah théoriquement
vous pouvez avoir une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale si vous avez une
droite une majorité et un RN qui vote le
texte mais ça veut dire que vous faites
passer votre texte grâce au RN contre
une partie de votre majorité contre le
président de votre commission des Lois
quand même contre certains groupes de
votre majorité en effet le modem donc
vous imaginez bien que ensuite et bien
vous avez 3 ans et demi à tenir avec une
majorité relative une majorité explosée
et une majorité dont une partie vous en
voudra alors justement c'est une
situation qui est embarrassante pour le
gouvernement et le grand absent de la
séance d'hier c'était Olivier dusopt la
gauche n'a cessé de rappeler son absence
a même demandé au gouvernement géralin
dans un avis de
recherche comment interpréter son
absence est-ce qu'il est gêné ce
ministre issu de l' de l'aile gauche par
ce texte qui a été considérablement
durci par la
droite je je sais pas s'il est gêné ce
qui est sûr c'est que d'abord les
relations
personnelle entre monsieur dusopt et
Monsieur Darmanin sont plutôt bonnes je
rappelle que Monsieur dusopt lorsque
Gérald Darmanin avait fait sa rentrée
politique au mois d'Out faisait partie
des ministres qui étai s'était rendu
dans le Nord pour assister à à
l'intervention de de Gérald darmanem
mais bien évidemment ça le met en
difficulté puisque c'était quand même
lui qui d'une certaine manière incarnait
cet article 3 du projet de loi donc
est-ce qu'il faut si vous voulez
interpréter son absence sur les bancs du
gouvernement au Sénat comm comme disons
un moyen de le protéger aussi face à un
texte dont on savait que de toute façon
il a être modifié par la par la majorité
sénatoriale c'est peut-être aussi
possible mais moi je crois qu'en effet
encore une fois la vraie difficulté
c'est la façon dont la trajectoire va se
définir à l'Assemblée nationale et
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle se définit
elle me paraît très incertaine et c'est
vrai que utiliser le 493 contre sa
majorité ou contre son opposition ce
n'est pas du tout la même chose
politiquement ça n'a pas
par que l'tilis contre sa majorité
d'unee manière c'est implicitement
reconnaître que cette majorité est
fortement divisé sur cette question ce
qui d'ailleurs serait quand même une
première depuis que Emmanuel Macron est
au pouvoir c'est-à-dire depuis 2017 là
en l'occurrence on aurait et c'est pas
surprenant parce qu'en fait sur la
question sur des questions de ce type
qui sont les questions migratoires ou
les questions régaliennes encore une
fois on se rend compte que ce que l'on
appelle de manière un peu triviale le en
même temps ça ne marche pas parce que
tout simplement cette majorité est très
composite quand même qu'on le Ve monom
au niveau des trajectoires politiques de
ses membres et en l'occurrence sur des
questions qui sont aussi clivantes on
retrouve les vieux clivages droite
gauche et c'est ce qu'il faut retenir je
crois finalement de cette discussion sur
ce projet de loi c'est que les clivage
droite gauche réapparaissent et il
réapparaissent à l'intérieur même de la
majorité et ça je crois que c'est la
première leçon qu'il faut tirer de ce de
cette séquence et comme on l'a vu au
Sénat plusieurs fois cette réactivation
du du clivage droite gauche est-ce que
là ce projet de lo immigration il a
vraiment montré une réactivation de ce
clivage il a jamais disparu ce clivage
sur un certain nombre de sujets il reste
structurant il reste structurant mais
fondamentalement et bien il ne l'est pas
sur je dirais les identités politiques
globales aujourd'hui en revanche
immigration retraite quand vous prenez
les enquêtes ça reste des éléments de
déterminant de une entité politique de
centre gauche ou de centre- droit et
évidemment pour la macronie qui s'est
construit sur une vision commune
notamment de la politique économique ces
sujets sont des sujets extrêmement
radioactif souvenez-vous la première
rupture de la majorité sous la
précédente législature c'est la loi
colon c'est la loi immigration et là on
St déjà des tensions le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que la majorité est
beaucoup plus fragile beaucoup plus
relative et donc ce faisant ces tensions
risquent d'être encore plus délétaire
pour le gouvernement alors le 493 vous
l'avez dit tous les deux ça créerait des
problèmes au sein de la majorité mais
est-ce que ça créerait des problèmes
vis-à-vis de l'opinion publque parce que
là les Français soutiennent ce texte
est-ce que politiquement le gouvernement
aurait à perdre à utiliser
493 je ne sais pas c'est-à-dire que
manifestement ce à quoi on assiste
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois c'est
que cette banalisation du 493 même si
elle est décriée par les oppositions ne
semble pas dans l'opinion publique
véritablement aujourd'hui
choqué même si quelques études d'opinion
montrent que les Français considèrent
que parfois c'est utilisé de manière un
peu abusive oui l'opinion publique
soutient ce texte certes mais la vraie
question est de savoir si par exemple
tout à l'heure on parlait du
rassemblement national est-ce que le
rassemblement national aurait intérêt à
soutenir ce texte moi personnellement je
ne pense pas en l'occurrence contenu des
positions qui sont les positions
historiques du rassemblement national
pour le rassemblement national vu de sa
fenêtre ce texte c'est côè sur jambe de
bois d'une certaine manière
euh qu' disent mais c'est ce qu'ils
disent après c'est que si vous voulez le
texte pour l'instant que il prend forme
notamment après la discussion au Sénat
manifestement c'est un texte Benjamin
l'a dit très justement qui veut exprimer
finalement la prise en compte de la
demande de fermeté de l'opinion publique
mais qu'est-ce qui va l'emporter est-ce
que c'est finalement l'opposition plutôt
à Macron dans l'opinion publique ou
est-ce que c'est finalement la demande
de fermeté sur la question migratoire
c'est toujours très difficile de le dire
un dernier mot ce texte c'est un fétiche
politique en réalité il marque pas de
dév évolution fondamentale je dis pas
qu'il y a rien dedans mais les
évolutions elles sont pas fondamentales
je rappelle souvent il y a un projet de
loi sur l'immigration tous les 3 ans
donc l'opinion est en attente d'un
signal et l'objectif c'est de lui
envoyer un signal avant les européennes
donc quel que soit le contenu du texte
qui est probablement pas réellement
compris par la majorité des Français
parce que déjà très changeant et assez
complexe l'important c'est ce signal
donc ce faisant le 49 àine à 3 vous
savez le 49 Aline à 3 l'important c'est
la dramaturgie est-ce que vous arrivez à
en faire un moment politique intense à
travers le sentiment que le gouvernement
on va l'exercer de manière autoritaire
réforme des retraites ou est-ce que
c'est banalisé parce qu'on est par
exemple sur un projet de loi de finance
la dramaturgie sur 49 Aline à 3 elle
prendra pas dans l'opinion mais elle
prendra dans la majorité et pour le
gouvernement c'est peut-être beaucoup
plus grave parce que l'opinion peut
oublier relativement rapidement l'usage
dans 49 àine à 3 ces députés
souvenez-vous des frondeurs non on va
passer à l'autre sujet de ce club et
cette question Sam bien qui divise la
classe politique faut-il marcher contre
l'antisémitisme au côté du rassemblement
national oui cette marche c'est un appel
commun je le rappelle des présidents de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat y Bron
pivé et jérard arché appellent à être
défilé dimanche prochain contre
l'antisémitisme et pour la République et
le premier parti avoir répondu à leur
appel et bien c'est le rassemblement
national Marine Le Pen ad dit caliré
Jordan Bardella il sera aussi et ça ça
met très mal à l'aise he toute une
partie de la classe politique a commencé
par la gauche au Sénat les écologistes
et les socialistes ont écrit à Gérard
Larcher voici leur message je cite on ne
peut défiler contre l'antisémitisme avec
ses plus fidèles légataires nous
demandons donc solennellement de
clarifier ce qui doit rester l'évidence
l'extrême droite n'a pas sa place sa
place dans cette marche fin de citation
et que répond Gérard Larchet bien il
était l'invité hier de nos confrères de
TF1 avec yel Bron pivé la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a été elle très
claire sur ce point pas question de dire
qui a le droit de devenir ou non à cette
marche contre l'antisémitisme regardez
il n'est pas question de savoir s'ils
doivent être les bienvenue en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est que le
président du Sénat et moi-même nous
défilerons en tête de ce cortège et nous
ne défilerons pas à côté du
rassemblement national alors les
écologistes les socialistes et les
communistes seront bien à la marche et
eux aussi voudrai bien être sûr de ne
pas défiler côte à côte avec le
rassemblement national qu'il considère
comme un parti aux racines antisémite il
réclame donc une sorte de cordon
sanitaire autour du RN mais Gérard
Larcher n'en veut pas nous nous appelons
les citoyens je reviens sur mon mot de
sursaut vous savez j'ai entendu parler
de cordon républicain le vrai cordon
républicain il est contre
l'antisémitisme et pour la République
pas question donc un disolé le
rassemblement national dans cette marche
il pourra y participer dans les mêmes
conditions que tout à chacun il faut
quand même dire he que les écologistes
socialistes et communistes ne sont pas
les seuls à être embarrassé par la
présence de l'extrême droite dans cette
marche hier c'est le porte-parole du
gouvernement lui-même Olivier verrand
qui est a estimé je cite que le
rassemblement national n'a pas sa place
dans cette marche même s'il a la liberté
d'y participer la première ministre
élisabette borne a annoncé pour sa part
qu'elle irit on ne sait pas encore si
Emmanuel Macron lui-même va y aller ce
qui est sûr en revanche c'est que la
France insoumise elle et bien n'ira pas
Jean-Luc Mélenchon estime que cette
marche serait je cite le rendez-vous des
amis du soutien inconditionnel au
massacre sous-entendu un soutien au
bombardement israélien sur la bande de
Gaza des propos qui bien sûr ont fait
polémique ouais on va revenir sur les
propos de la France insoumise euh mais
d'abord cette division politique sur un
sujet qui devrait faire consensus la
lutte contre
l'antisémitisme comment vous vous la
comprenez Benjamin comment vous
l'analysez ben en fait c'est le même
problème depuis le début de la
législature souvenez-vous première
premier moment de la législature à
l'Assemblée nationale l'élection de
yelbron pivé Sébastien Chenu retire sa
candidature ensuite et donc il permet
l'élection au deuxème tour il a le probl
pivé sinon il aurait fallu attendre le
trème ensuite composition du bureau
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec le RN et C 89
députés à l'époque ben vice-présidence
et cetera la réalité c'est que ce parti
aujourd'hui n'a qu'un objectif c'est de
donner des gages de normalisation
j'étais pas d'accord avec Arne là-dessus
sur le projet de loi immigration si
jamais il votent le projet de loi
immigration ils disent regardez c'est
peut-être un petit texte mais nous nous
normalisons grâce à nous vous aurez une
majorité grâce à nous vous n'utiliserez
pas le 49 Alina 3 nous sommes
responsables c'est leur objectif
aujourd'hui dans l'opinion à dessin de
se crédibiliser et là en effet c'est pas
un piège que tient le que tend le RN
c'était très prévisible c'est-à-dire que
vous organisez une marche contre
l'antisémitisme si vous marchez avec eux
vous acceptez de dire ce parti n'est
plus le parti Jean-Marie Le Pen ce parti
n'est plus le parti antisémite qu'il a
pu avoir la réputation d'être et donc ce
faisant vous participez à leur stratégie
de crédibilisation mais vous ne pouvez
pas non plus leur refuser d'être présent
à cette manifestation et donc le dilemme
qui pouvait être celui du RN il y a
quelques années se reporte sur les
autres partis politiques et aujourd'hui
face à cette évolution du rassemblement
national l'ensemble du spectre du
spectre politique est très embêté c'est
soit l'isoler soit et bien le cautionner
et entre les deux ben ni l'une ni
l'autre des options ne sont tout à fait
possibles ouais ça veut dire qu'il y a
pas de il y a pas de solution très
claire pour les autres partis politiques
c'est d'abord il faut quand même noter
une chose c'est que quand on regarde ce
qui est en train de se passer par
rapport au moment tragique que le pays a
connu notamment en 2015 après l'attentat
contre Charlie Hebdo ou ensuite après le
l'attentat du du Bataclan le 13 novembre
j'allais dire que l'atmosphère a
considérablement changé c'est-à-dire que
finalement l'unité politique aujourd'hui
semble plutôt assez loin d'accès pour la
classe politique et on le voit bien
autour des polémiques concernant cette
mobilisation
ensuite si vous voulez moi je pense que
ça POS surtout un problème à la gauche
fondamentalement parce que d'abord le
problème de la gauche c'est que elle n'a
pas résolu son son problème par rapport
à LFI déjà parce que ce qu'il faut aussi
entendre au-delà de la polémique autour
de la présence souhaitée ou pas
souhaiter des élus du du rassemblement
national dans cette manifestation c'est
que Monsieur Mélenchon et la France
insoumise disent ne pas vouloir
participer à cette manifestation non pas
tant à cause du rassemblement national
même si il dénonce la présence des élus
du rassemblement national en rappelant
les les racines du Front national mais
surtout parce que il considè que cette
manifestation si l'on entend par exemple
les propos d'un député comme Monsieur
guireud hier sur une chaîne concurrente
de la vôtre considère que cette
manifestation est un soutien qui serait
apporté à Israël pour et je prends des
guillemets nettoyer ethniquement la zone
de Gaza donc il y a quand même un
problème à gauche déjà sur le fond
ensuite moi je pense que très
franchement
aujourd'hui c'est un débat qui est
interne à la classe politique mais je
serais très intéressé de savoir ce qu'en
pense l'opinion publique parce que quand
on regarde quand même la plupart des
études aujourd'hui d'opinion elle montre
que elle considère que elle donne kitous
à la stratégie de normalisation et de
banalisation du rassemblement national
porté par Marine Le Pen ensuite
évidemment si l'on se réfère à
l'histoire de ce que fut le Front
national à sa création c'est-à-dire dans
les années 70 et au début des années 80
c'est un parti qui clairement était un
parti qui appartenait à ce que l'on peut
qualifier aujourd'hui d'extrême droite
la vraie question c'est de savoir
aujourd'hui et ça c'est une question moi
que j'ai beaucoup de mal à à trancher
c'est que est-ce que le rassemblement
national peut être considéré aujourd'hui
encore comme parti d'extrême droite en
fonction des critères qui sont ceux que
l'on que l'on que l'on utilise pour
caractériser l'extrême droite
manifestement quand même Marine Le Pen a
plus que donné des gages d'ailleurs elle
a donné un gage qui est un gage à mon
avis très fort sur le plan politique
puisque elle a exclu du Front national
en 2000 je sais plus c'était en 2015 ou
2014 sont fond c'est-à-dire Jean-Marie
Le Pen donc c'est extrêmement difficile
aujourd'hui comp tenu de l'évolution
politique du rassemblement national et
contenu du fait aussi que le
rassemblement national a un groupe
parlementaire avec 88 parlementaires à
l'Assemblée nationale de dire on ne veut
pas le rassemblement national à cette
manifestation sur la gauche puisque
Arnaud en parlait Bruno retaillot il y a
quelques minutes disait que la l'absence
pardon d'fi à cette manifestation en
fait il se servait de la présence du RN
comme d'un prétexte probablement bah la
stratégie de la France insoumise est
peut-être en partie cynique mais pas
tout à fait idiote c'est-à-dire que
l'idée c'est de bétonner un électorat
cet électorat vous lui envoyez des
signaux extrêmement je dirais directs et
peu subtille en disant regardez dans ce
sur ce sujet nous sommes les seuls qui
représentons quelque peu vos intérêts
vos pensé et cetera or celui qui gagne
une élection dans une période de
multipolarisation de la vie politique et
d'abstention relativement importante
c'est pas celui qui a le plus large
électorat c'est celui qui mobilise le
mieux son électorat tout bêtement parce
que vous avez une masse critique et
qu'ensuite vous pouvez déclencher un
effet de vote utile la fi parie sur deux
choses la mobilisation de son électorat
le fait qu'il y a personne d'autre que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon aujourd'hui qui
puisse incarner quelque chose de manière
très très forte à gauche et que donc il
devrait y avoir un effet de vot utile et
que Infiné et bien cette mise en
visibilité cette mise en tension
permettent réellement d'incarner pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon une forme
d'alternance et d'Alter native en ça je
veux dire cette stratégie là d'un point
de vue strictement cynico-électoral elle
est pas si idiote après évidemment elle
est très très cynique et elle donne le
sentiment et bien que la France
insoumise 1 peut participer à une forme
de normalisation du RN par contraste ce
qui peut lui être reproché par certains
et de l'autre côté que l'idée que le
parti puisse demain gouverner et bien
apparaît comme étant plutôt repoussoir
pour une majorité des français quand
vous regardez les dernières enquêtes
Arnaud il nous reste 20 secondes non
rapidement moi je pense que la nor
isation du rassemblement national a
commencé bien avant d'ailleurs cette
législature ensuite moi je pense que
c'est une stratégie très risquée de la
part de Jean-Luc mulenchant je comprends
tout à fait l'analyse de Benjamin
c'est-à-dire on renforce son soccle
électoral dans un premier temps et
ensuite de toute façon comment on aura
ce socle électorat qui nous permettra
d'être devant tout le monde on aura un
phénomène de vote utile moi ça me paraît
risqué au regard de l'état de l'opinion
publique aujourd'hui en France et on
suivra bien évidemment cette manche
cette marche pardon dimanche à
l'initiative de Gérard larch brun pivé
la une de nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionau Samia du P decaléis à la Corse
les inondations font la une des
quotidiens régionaux ce matin oui la
Picardie est touché à l'air ce matin le
Courrier Picard alors que le Pas de
Calais repasse en vigilance crue et
pluie inondation en vigilance rouge ce
jeudi le département on le sait est
frappé par des inondations historiques
on s'est senti couperé du monde raconte
des sinistrés dans la VO voie du Nord
qui ont quand même passé 48 he dans le
noir sans chauffage coupée du monde elle
aussi la vallée de la Restonica fait la
Une de Corse Matin des centaines de
mètres de route ont été emportés par les
intempéries la semaine dernière en
auverne les chiffres de l'immobilier
sont alarmants oui on est proche du
crash prévient ce matin la montagne le
nombre de ventes a chuté de 53 % en
Auvergne cette année forcément on
construit aussi de moins en moins ça
crée une pénurie y compris dans le
logement social et c'est une véritable
bombe à retardement s'inquiète une
député du département on parle de foot
une affiche de rêve c'est à la Une de La
Dépêche de midi oui ce soir Toulouse
affronte Liverpool les supporters rêvent
d'un exploit au match allé en Angleterre
le TFC s'était fait écraser 5 à 1 cette
fois les Toulousains jouent à domicile
pour ce match retour de la Ligue Europa
ils ont tout à gagner mais aussi un peu
à perdre écrit La Dépêche sur cette
équipe qui a enchaîné les défaites ces
derniers temps il faudrait un exploit
pour l'emporter face aux Anglais on le
souhaite au toulousain on termine en
musique ça va jazer à 9h ce weekend oui
il y a 27 concerts en 8 jours c'est
parti pour la 37 7e édition du Jazz
Festival de Never qui s'ouvre samedi le
programme est à découvrir dans le
Journal du Centre ce matin il y aura des
têtes d'affiches mais aussi des
découvertes qui font l'ADN de ce
festival merci Samia merci beaucoup pour
cette revue de presse ARN on regarde la
une de la revue politique et
parlementaire le savant le politique et
le peuple en jeu du siècle tout à fait
c'était le thème de nos rencontres de
saint-raaphaël cette année voilà et
c'est à lire dans ce numéro de la revue
politique et parlementaire merci Arna
Benedetti merci Benjamin Morel et merci
Samien pour cette longue nuit à suivre
le projet de
immigration vous le suivrez d'ailleurs
toute la journée encore sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat nous on se retrouve demain
à Strasbourg pour une émission spéciale
au cœur du Congrès des départements très
bonne journée à
demain